this is Startalk for about 30-40 years
we used the classic Drake Equation which
said all right life evolves in these
little places around the galaxy and
that's all we have to calculate but then
it was pointed out that interstellar
travel is not impossible certainly not
with robots that might copy themselves
and probably colonization of some kind
or another is possible in which case
you're not you're talking about more
like spreading zones and how long would
it take for such a spreading zone if you
had starships that just traveled 10% of
the speed of light and make planted
colonies and then they build up their
civilization and then spread out and
planted more colonies it turns out you
could fill the galaxies within 60
million years which is an eyeblink
there's nothing yeah so the the question
of where is everybody and why aren't we
seeing them is made vastly worse if you
allow any kind of interstellar travel
right because they started anywhere they
should already be everywhere that's
right and so the one of the things I
talked about my novel existence is how
when we get out to the asteroid belt or
the Kuiper belt we may find an entire
civilization or perhaps they fought of
various types of space probes that were
sent by previous cultures and we'll
probably be sending such
self-replicating probes but the other
half of the question is you know how
likely is it that at any of these
spacing intervals we're going to likely
be able to detect others and those
calculations have been done and and it
turns out we're at a borderline the
earth itself would only be detectable to
very super advanced aliens with huge
antennas that they aim deliberately at
us for a year and then they might pick
up I Love Lucy so right now when they
product range the channel
the barn door excuse for Metis is it's
too late they already know about us but
it turns out that is simply and
scientifically wrong the people who want
to use these planetary radars to send
focused beams out into space going
yoo-hoo
they intend to change the current
situation by yelling very very loudly
and very focused ly so now the the fear
of that would be that we attract the
Borg is that basically it and before you
know what we're all serving overlords
that come here and yeah I mean the thing
is you you can put it that way and it's
it's easy to make fun of because there
are there's so much questionable science
fiction about about aliens coming to
invade us so no a lot of people think
it's even it's a silly thing to worry
about
but David Brin is written about this and
he's actually persuaded me that if you
if you use the precautionary principle
you have to ask well can we prove that
it's not a threat and are we certain
that it's not and are there some logical
explanations for what we observe that
might be consistent with dangerous
aliens and then if you admit that you
can't prove that it's not some
existential threat then you have to say
okay well then what on what basis did we
decide that it's okay to risk the future
of Earth's biosphere risk it turns out
that that there are mature ways to do
this 20 years ago the genetic
engineering and genetic research
communities in biology hold a moratorium
on genetic research and had a meeting at
Asilomar California and came out with
better practices best practices that'll
let us have our cake and eat it too
let us have advances in genetic research
while taking some very very solid and
mature precautions and the NASA has a
planetary protection office whose job it
is to make sure that the space
we land on other worlds have been
sterilized as best we can but not in a
way that makes it so that we can't
explore but but just as best we can and
of course these precautions are done ten
times a hundred times as strongly if
we're going to be returning stuff you
know to earth it might infect the earth
so there are mature ways of doing this
and from what you say though the the the
it only takes one space herpe that's all
it takes is one space herpe to ruin
everything David you know the virus is
not herpes yeah you know what I'm saying
I don't want to mess with that nobody
wants to put a salve on the sore that
shows up from that space her pee that's
all I'm saying
talking we're talking about safe SETI
here is exact same ember to practice
safe steady folks